can you talk about turning on the camera
and approaching the subject without
judgment you had mentioned that you
spoke to these gentlemen
with kindness you know just there
they're still human beings they still
respond to you know people being nice
but at some point you had to show them
it just who they are and you approached
it without judgment how does a
documentary and do that when they have
strong feelings about the subject I
think that you know I had a screening
for this film for prison guards once in
Denmark and it was really interesting
they put words to something that I think
we really as filmmakers must do whenever
we look at another human being they said
we always try to separate the crime from
the person and I insist
I've never per second suspended my
judgment of the crimes my I think my
moral point of view throughout the film
never flags and throughout the
filmmaking never flagged but I insisted
to myself that I see these men as human
beings because I know the moment that I
condemned them as monsters or see Anwar
as a psychopath what I'm doing is
actually mainly reassuring myself that
I'm not like them
and that if the film has any core
message it's that we are all much closer
to perpetrators than we like to think
indeed every article of clothing
touching my body now is haunted by the
suffering of the people who make it for
us and we know that all of them without
exception are working in places like
Indonesia that everything we buy is
produced in places like Indonesia where
there's been mass violence or
perpetrators of one and in their victory
they built regimes of fear that keep
people to suppress the to get the human
cost of everything we buy incorporated
in the price tag that we pay we have
stories to justify these economists have
stories to justify this we I think know
it and we tell ourselves that the
trousers were wearing are Hugo Boss and
not the work of virtual slaves but the
work of a fashion designer so as to
forget the true nature of our reality I
think the film asks people to look at
the nature of reality and I knew that if
for a moment I see these men as anything
other than
human I'm once again escaping from the
reality by telling myself I'm not like
them so I insisted to myself I always
see amar and his friends as human beings
and I and in order to deal with that and
I think that I feel I can't make a film
honestly about another human being
showing what we human beings are capable
of if I don't oh wait if I don't get
allow myself to get close to them and I
insisted that okay I would be close to
him and if for a moment I see him as a
monster or a psychopath I will stop I
will withdraw I'll take some days off to
rest I'll come back and approach him as
one human being to another now that was
difficult because when you become close
to someone when you become intimate with
someone
of course you become vulnerable to them
and so hearing these awful stories
seeing these awful things then gave me
nightmares because I was open to the
fact that I would hope I would never do
these things but I'm very lucky never to
have to find out and so I would have
these nightmares then I would be afraid
of the nightmares that gave me insomnia
for four weeks four months and I think I
if I got through it it was because of
the support and the friendship and the
love of my Indonesian crew in particular
who was going through much the same
thing and who in a way I think together
we tried to light what was a very dark
journey for each other with our care
with our friendship with our left
you